the third installment of the Uncharted
franchise are one of the most
anticipated games of the year no
pressure
uncharted three drake's Deception I
suppose you've seen before I'm a huge
fan of the Uncharted games everyone
knows that and now we have uncharted
three drake's Deception it's getting
like 10 out of 10 score ratings so in
uncharted 3 you meet up with Nathan
Drake again Victor Sullivan they're
going after the Atlantis of the sands
because apparently in Sir Francis
Drake's voyage you took it like six
months to do something that should have
taken him one so they're like ah
something's amiss something tells me
it's in the Atlantis of the sands real
time Indiana Jones and it is and of
course when you're Nathan Drake and
you're going after a treasure there are
bad people who want to go after the
treasure also and make your day a little
worse and this one is this bad chick
who's totally rich and looks like she'd
be played by Helen Mirren if it was a
movie which I'm not gonna lie am I the
only guy who has an attraction to Helen
Mirren it's weird and this other guy
named Talbot of course his name is
Talbot Talbot is a villain name I've
never known a good guy in a movie or a
game name Talbot they're always
and of course this guy is an now
first of all the gameplay the gameplay
in this game really hasn't added much
but it was like perfect in the second
game so if it ain't broke don't fix it
the only real mechanic that they have
that's new is that when people throw a
grenades at you if you push a button at
the right time you'll take the grenade
and throw it back at him which is really
useful angle I another cool thing it's
not really a gameplay mechanic but it's
just kind of an animation when you're
beating someone up sometimes he'll take
the grenade on their belt and pull the
pin and kick them back and so the guy
just blows up as Bruce Wayne
other than that same stuff you're like
spider crawling up walls because Nathan
Drake's apparently the most fit human
being on the planet hopping head shots
looking for treasures you know it's
classic uncharted this is staple
uncharted game playing you know how in
the second game there were these moments
where it was like a cutscene was
happening but you can play through it
it's just like this action scene and
things are crumbling around you there
are few of those moments in uncharted 3
and they're the most intense things I've
ever played in the first one this
mansion is like burning to the ground
you saw it in the trailer and it's just
like it was so real I'm not gonna lie to
you I could smell the smoke of the fire
either that or I have a brain tumor and
it's amazing I'm alive right now either
way I don't care it was realistic as
hell and the plane scene from the
trailer and the ship see like there are
moments where you're like Nathan Drake
just causes bad guys to have a really
really bad day like there's a scene
where you're in this huge ship watch
this big tanker and you're
walking outside and the camera pans up
to show the damage that you've done and
I was just like Nathan Drake has driven
this bad guy to alcoholism and that's
what he does you know when bad guys have
him tied up it's like just tell them
already because he's going to burn your
empire to the ground and talk while
he's doing it cuz he's Nathan Drake and
he's awesome he's like the man's man we
all want to be Nathan Drake I mean some
of his friends do tell me like dude what
are you trying to prove don't go after
this which I really liked also because
you know when you're going after a
treasure or a trinket and people with
ak-47s are shooting at you throwing
grenades at you shooting RPGs at you and
trying to kill you and your friends your
friends are probably gonna be like you
know what I don't think we should do
this anymore so I'm glad this game
addressed that and the soundtrack in
this game it's like some of the best
game music I've ever heard like outside
of an RPG RPGs always have the best
stuff but in terms of action game
uncharted 3 this is really good but
there's a scene where you're running
from people I don't want to give it away
because telling you the context would
kind of be a spoiler but the music that
plays when you're running it's the best
I want that song I want the soundtrack
comes out on November 14th or 15th or
something like that
I'll get it uncharted 3 is like Firefly
meets Indiana Jones in modern day and
sometimes it's like that show I
shouldn't be alive like when you're in
the rouble Kali does it you're like I
shouldn't be alive and you really feel
that you really feel the isolation of
Nathan Drake it's badass now of course
this is the third chapter of a trilogy
and in that they delve into some of the
past and Nathan Drake which is awesome I
love seeing that but that's also kind of
where some of my issues with the game
are by even addressing Nathan Drake's
past the game has opened the door in
your brain that makes you go oh awesome
I want to know more about that it does
show a bit about his past and you love
seeing what you see you're like that is
cool I'm glad I saw that but they tell
you there is more to the story and there
are secrets and you just don't get to
know them that irritated me and in
uncharted 3 in the first half of the
game you kind of deal with these
characters over here in the second half
you deal with these characters over here
the two parties never cross and that's a
bummer because in uncharted 2 you had
Chloe you had Elena you had Victor
Sullivan you had that one dude who would
have been played by Bradley Cooper if it
was a movie and you know there was some
tension between some characters and
there was some betrayal and there was
some tension between Chloe and Elena and
that was awesome the characters really
worked well together from start to
finish
I loved how they all interacted together
and it all worked in this game it kind
of felt isolated it's like alright you
get these characters here second half of
the game you get these characters here
no one really stabs them in the back
like in the second game it doesn't
change the fact that in terms of
exciting
shinsen gameplay and charted three has
some of the best I have ever seen in my
life sometimes things happen in this
game you're like I can't believe that
happened that's like the coolest thing
that would happen in like some of the
biggest budget movies ever these
playable scenes where things are getting
destroyed around you done match some
people may have a problem with the fact
that there's no real end boss fight in
this game either I'm fine with it but I
think some other people might just
about it do you it might catch you off
guard if you're expecting a big boss
fight at the end you don't get the big
boss fight that you got in uncharted 2
it kind of ends as the story would end
and that's what uncharted is all about
it's a playable movie I'm still going to
give it a great score of Awesome tacular
in terms of the multiplayer the
multiplayer beta that I reviewed is
pretty much the multiplayer so if you
want to see my review of the multiplayer
go ahead and check out my review of the
multiplayer that I did like months ago
I'll put a link at the end of this video
cuz I'm there for you so if you haven't
played the Uncharted games for God's
sakes play the Uncharted games if you
have a Playstation you haven't gotten
uncharted 3 did why get this game play
this game no this game love this game if
you don't have a PlayStation 3 just find
a friend with a PlayStation 3 and get it
get the whole series and play it all
because if you don't
hmm so the Uncharted series have you
played them what is your favorite
Uncharted game comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you